le ha costado diez años y seis meses en
prisión pero él si finalmente recuperó
su libertad tras lograr conmutar su
condena de 30 años acusada de homicidio
agravado después de sufrir un aborto
espontáneo
gracias
gracias porque cada día
luchando
y siguen luchando
por las compañeras de todavía en qué
edad
ya son pocas
y sé que así como yo he salido este día
así también es un día van a poder
obtener su libertad y van a poder estar
constante en 2011 esta madre sufrió un
aborto por complicaciones obstétricas y
cuando buscó ayuda médica fue acusada de
haberlo provocado y fue procesada
penalmente
ya que el aborto está prohibido en el
país incluso bajo causales como
violación incesto o peligro para la vida
de la mujer algo criticado por los
colectivos de los derechos de las
mujeres como la agrupación ciudadana por
la despenalización del aborto
su errónea sentencia de 30 años por
homicidio agravado ha terminado debemos
seguir luchando incansable y
colectivamente para liberar a las que
siguen privadas de libertad sólo en las
últimas dos décadas 181 mujeres han sido
juzgadas tras sufrir complicaciones
obstétricas en el salvador a través de
la lucha del movimiento feminista desde
diciembre de 2021 5 mujeres con este
tipo de condenas han sido liberadas de
prisión pero no todos se han corrido de
la misma suerte como en el caso de
manuela que murió en la cárcel tras ser
condenada a 30 años por infringir las
leyes del aborto una pena condenada por
la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos